there would be no oxygen left neither
one of them and stop talking your pal
Kelly Clarkson I mean you guys go way
way back how's it feel to finally get
her on the show well I can tell you that
I used to think you know that Miley
Cyrus would be the person that talks the
most ever in the history of this show
except and now that they brought in
Kelly Clarkson oh my god if they oh my
god and thank god they're at least on
different seasons because my ears would
fall off of my head with Jay HUD and
Kelly come in obviously been on the
other side of singing competitions what
advice would you give them as their
first time as coaches I could give a
crap about helping them I don't have any
advice I'm not helping them I don't want
them to succeed that's not what they pay
me to do they don't belong here either I
mean it's kind of bittersweet to say
goodbye to Alicia Keys for next couple
seasons his main competition I'm sure
he's happy to see me go so he doesn't
feel such a stress and a pressure every
time he works with me okay your response
mr. Shelton
I've looked ahead and it's this is like
those Harry Potter movies you know
characters you think they're gone but
then they come back and Alicia I've
already looked ahead on the script and
they have her coming back using it right
here show are you breaking news Alicia's
coming back yes Alicia will be back
[Music]
you